now
the polish prime minister matteis
morovietsky has called the labor crisis
excuse me the border crisis with belarus
the greatest attempt to destabilize
europe since the cold war the
humanitarian situation shows no signs of
easing as poland continues to push back
migrants trying to cross illegally they
face harsh winter conditions out in the
forest along the border another migrant
has been buried by members of poland's
muslim community more than 10 people
have died in recent weeks while trying
to cross into the european union
and for more we're joined now by our
reporter amy and isif who is in the
polish city of ha nyovka
amien i know you've been out there for a
few days now just tell us about what the
situation is there today
as you said christine the situation
shows no sign of abating the checkpoints
here like the one you see behind me are
still firmly in place all throughout the
region near the border
the exclusion zone around the border is
also still firmly in place
keeping anybody from the media or from
aid organizations from accessing the
area around the border about 6 000
troops have been deployed here and more
are coming estonia has promised 100
troops um the uk has uh promised a
hundred as well as you can see there's a
military vehicle passing me right now a
lot of military activity in the region
that's because the polish border guard
says that every night around 200 people
tried to breach the border into poland
from the belarusian side we know for a
fact that several people had made it
through last night we had contact
through a source
that showed us dropped us a pin where
these people were camped out on the
polish side and that is worrying because
these temperatures have been dropping
this is the coldest day so far this week
around -3 celsius or 25 degrees
fahrenheit last night and hypothermia is
the number one reason why people get
sent by migrants have been sent to
hospitals in poland according to local
volunteers
um we know that hundreds of migrants are
still stranded in the forest we also
know that others were taken into
shelters in belarus can you give us an
overview of that situation
it's very difficult christine to give
any kind of overview of a situation like
this because of the media blackout in
this area in the woods around the border
as i said we had contact through a
source of people who were in the woods
but contact with the people themselves
is very difficult the number one reason
being that they're hiding from
authorities they don't trust many people
to to contact them
because they know that if they are found
either by emergency services or by the
police they will they there's a chance
that they will be brought immediately
back to the fence and illegally pushed
back to belarus poland has a law in
place
since the end of october that says they
can do this even though it's illegal
according to international law so what
is really happening to the migrants is a
mystery but what we do see is when they
do come out of the woods when they're
desperate enough to call the the medical
services and risk being sent back to
belarus they end up in a hospital or
they end up as you said uh being buried
because they did not survive the cold
nights here in the woods without a tent
or any resources
amy how is the polish government
handling this crisis and what support
is poland getting from the european
union
the polish government has more or less
split this into two different issues the
humanitarian issue which they put over
to the belarusian side and the political
issue now they've really only taken up
the mantle of the political issue that's
why uh the prime minister has been doing
a tour of the baltic states to drum up
support for the polish military the
polish border guard but they haven't
been addressing the humanitarian issue
now on the political side of course
there is no signs of de-escalation the
the polish side is in fact escalating by
bringing in more troops trying to
show a display of force against belarus
they've warned of
more things to come they said more
worrying things to come meaning that
this could devolve into a real conflict
with belarus but the humanitarian side
as i said has not been addressed that
crisis is ongoing we've seen
the the council of europe call for
poland to allow aid workers to get into
this
region of woods just beyond where i'm
standing where uh for now they have no
access and as i said winter is coming
this is going to devolve into a worse
situation if nothing is done about that
all right that's dwe's reporter amy and
um in the polish town of hanyovka that's
at that border between poland and
belarus thank you amy and for your
reporting